welcome to Simply learn today we take
you to the future of networking in this
tutorial video we are going to get on an
exciting journey into the dynamic world
of network engineering specifically
focusing on how to become a network
engineer in the year 2024 with
technology evolving at an unprecedented
Pace the role of network Engineers has
never been more crucial we will uncover
the latest industry Trends Cutting Edge
Technologies and essential skills that
you need to thrive in the ever evolving
landscape of networking whether you're
just starting or looking to level up
your skills join us as we unlock the
secrets of a successful network
engineering career in 2024 and beyond
that said if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch then hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to
get notified and if you are a
professional with minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from the
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learns postgraduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
the right choice for more details head
straight to our homepage and search for
postgraduate program in cyber security
from MIT University or simply click on
the link in the description box below
now without further delay over to our
training so without further delay let's
get started by discussing the agenda for
today's session first we will understand
who is a network engineer followed by
that we will learn the important skills
required for you to become a network
engineer then we will go through the
roles and responsibilities of a network
engineer then the most important point
of today's discussion that is how to
become a network engineer or or the road
map to become a network engineer
followed by that we will discuss the
salary compensations offered by the
major emenes to a network engineer and
we will wrap up the discussion by
discussing some of the biggest mnc's
which are hiring Network Engineers as of
now now let's get started with the first
pointer which is who is a network
engineer computer network Architects and
Engineers design and build data
communication Network and monitor
Network systems these could range in
size from a connection between couple of
offices to an intricate Cloud
infrastructure serving a multinational
company Network Engineers are often also
responsible for protecting these
networks from all sorts of external
threats from fishing schemes to
ransomware to denial of service attacks
with a process known as network security
at smaller companies you may be
responsible for both architecture and
security working in larger companies
often means specializing in one area of
network engineering such as architecture
security or Administration now now
moving ahead we will learn the important
skills required to become a network
engineer Network Engineers require a
diverse set of skills to effectively
design Implement and maintain Network
infrastructure here are the top five
important skills for a network engineer
first networking fundamentals a strong
understanding of networking Basics is
essential this includes knowledge of
network protocols such as TCP IP DNS
DHCP and HTTP as well understanding how
data travels through networks is also
critical this fundamental knowledge
forms the basis of more advanced
networking tasks next is routing and
switching Network Engineers need to be
proficient in configuring and managing
routers and switches this involves
understanding routing protocols like
ospf and bgp as well as weans spanning
tree protocols and other switching
Technologies they must be able to design
and troubleshoot complex Network
architectures as well next is network
security security is critical aspect of
modern networking Network Engineers need
to be well vered in network security
best practices this includes knowledge
of firewalls intrusion detection and
prevention systems VPN and the ability
to identify and mitigate security
threats and vulnerabilities cyber
security certifications like certified
information system security professional
or also known as
cisp can be valuable next ahead is
network monitoring and troubleshooting
Network Engineers should be skilled in
using network monitoring tools to
proactively identify issues and maintain
Network performance they need to
troubleshoot network problems
efficiently often under time constraints
knowledge of tools like wire shock and
SNMP is helpful and the ability to
analyze Network traffic is a valuable
skill lastly communication and
collaboration effective communication is
essential as Network Engineers often
work with cross functional teams and
need to explain complex technical issues
to non-technical stakeholders
collaboration skills are crucial when
working with other it professionals such
as system administrators Security
Experts and application developers
moving ahead we will discuss the
important roles and responsibilities of
a network engineer Network Engineers
play a crucial role in designing
implementing and maintaining
infrastructure that allows organizations
to communicate and function effectively
here are five important roles and
responsibilities of a network engineer
firstly Network design and planning
evaluate the organization's Network
requirements and Design Network
Solutions that meet the needs plan and
architect Network infrastructure
including choosing the right Hardware
software and protocols consider
scalability redundency and Security in
network design next is Network
implementation configure and deploy
network devices such as routers switches
firewalls and load balances set up
virtual private networks or VPN for
secure remote access install and
maintain Network ging ensuring it meets
industry standards the third one is
network maintenance and troubleshooting
monitor Network performance traffic and
security to identify and resolve issues
promply Implement Network updates
patches and firmware upgrades to ensure
Optimal Performance and security
troubleshoot network problems including
connectivity issues latency and packet
loss the fourth role and responsibility
is security and compliance Implement
security measur to protect the network
from cyber threats including configuring
firewalls intrusion detection systems
and encryption protocols ensure
compliance with industry standards and
regulations such as gdpr Hippa or PCI
DSS depending on the organization's
needs conduct security Audits and
vulnerability assessments to proactively
identify and lastly we have
documentation and Reporting maintain
detailed documentation of network
configurations changes and and diagrams
create and update Network documentation
which is essential for triple shooting
and ensuring consistency generate
reports or network performance of time
and security incidents for management
and compliance purposes in addition to
these roles and responsibilities Network
Engineers often collaborate with other
it and non-it teams within an
organization to ensure that the network
supports the business goals and
objectives they must also stay updated
with the latest Technologies and best
practices to keep the network secure and
efficient in the face of evolving
threats and changing business needs now
the important point of today's
discussion that is how to become a
network engineer so the first step is
education obtain a bachelor's degree in
computer science information technology
or a related field while a degree is not
always mandatory it can significantly
improve your chances of securing a job
additionally taking courses in
networking cyber security and
Telecommunications can provide a solid
foundation next one is gain basic it
experience start by gaining experience
in basic it rules such as technical
support to develop a strong
understanding of computer systems and
troubleshooting this will help you grasp
fundamental concepts before specializing
in networking third one is develop
networking skills learn about networking
fundamentals including Network protocols
routing and switching Lan or van
Technologies and network security online
courses tutorials and self-study can be
useful in iring these skills moving
ahead we have certifications pursue
industry recognized certifications such
as Cisco certified Network associate or
also known as CCNA or comp tier Network
Plus or Juniper Networks certified
associate also known as
jncia these certifications validate your
Knowledge and Skills in networking and
can make you more competitive in the job
market moving ahead we have the fifth
step which is hands-on experience gain
hands-on experience by setting up up and
managing small networks at home or
through internships practice configuring
routers switches and fireballs and
troubleshoot network issues to enhance
your practical skills now moving ahead
we have the sixth step stay updated stay
informed about the latest networking
Technologies Trends and best practices
through online forums industry
Publications and networking events
continuous learning is crucial in
rapidly evolving field of networking now
the seventh step that is soft skills
develop strong communication problem
solving and teamwork skills Network
Engineers often work in teams and need
to communicate effectively with both
Technical and non-technical stakeholders
eighth one is to specialize consider
specializing in specific areas such as
network security Cloud networking or
Wireless networking to enhance your
expertise and career prospects the ninth
step build a network attend industry
events seminars and workshops to expand
your Professional Network networking
with Professionals in this field can
provide you with valuable insights and
potential job opportunities lastly apply
for jobs look for an entry-level
position such as network technician
Junior network engineer or network
administrator to Kickstart your career
update your resume and Linkedin profile
to highlight your skills and
certifications remember becoming a
network engineer is a continuous Journey
if you are in India and if you are a
beginner level network engineer then you
can expect salaries ranging from 250,000
to 450,000 per anom if you an
intermediate candidate with 1 to two
years of experience then you can expect
salaries ranging from 450,000 to 8 lakhs
per anom and if you're a highly
experienced candidate that is experience
more than 4 years then you can expect a
minimum salary of 8 lakhs to 20 lakhs
per anom and if you're in America and if
you're a beginner then you can expect
salaries ranging from 50, ,000 to
$80,000 per Anum and if you're an
intermediate candidate with minimum 2
years of experience then you can expect
salaries from $80,000 to
$110,000 per anom and if you're a highly
experienced candidate that is more than
four years of experience then you can
expect salaries ranging from $110,000 to
$160,000 per anom now with this let us
move on to the top companies hiring
Network Engineers some of the biggest
Tech joints hiring Network engineers in
the industry are Cisco Systems am Amon
web services Microsoft Google Facebook
or meta IBM AT&T verison Communications
Dell HP and much more and with that we
have reached to the end of this session
on how to become a network engineer in
2024 should you need any assistance PPT
or any other resources used in the
session please let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be happy to help you as
soon as possible thank you and keep
learning stay tuned for more from Simply
learn staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporate ations
and delivered by industry experts choose
any of our programs and set yourself on
the path to Career Success click the
link in the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here